Why did you expect that my alpha fetal protein to a marker test will take a while to drop
after surgery?
Well, I didn't, if I said that I didn't, I misspoke, I didn't expect it to, it just
that's, I've just seen that sometimes it could take, you know, a few weeks for your
to a marker to drop post surgery.
Now, I did a brief, you know, search on the literature on any data of this, and I just
can't find any studies on when the tumor markers will drop and post surgery.
So that in fact, there's very little on the AFP tumor marker with breast cancer.
It's literally almost most of the research is done on liver cancer.
So it's hard to find any research on this stuff, so it's, it's very difficult.
It's just through the years of trying to help people with this, my, what I've noticed
is that two markers don't necessarily drop suddenly post surgery, so that's what I meant
to say.
Why might other two markers rise after surgery?
Again, you know, you remember that, you know, two markers are just one test, and it's
not perfect.
The only data that you can really find of what causes two markers to rise is, is, is, use
of chemotherapy.
And that certainly doesn't happen every time, you know, we have patients probably on this
call that did chemotherapy, that didn't cause their two markers to spike.
But I'll get, you know, tell you for sure, over the years, I've seen that lots of times where
people would start chemotherapy, so the two markers literally just won't skyrocket.
Some people's body doesn't respond the same way.
So all I'm saying is that there's not really any data that says that it's a bad thing that
two markers are dropping quickly.
There's no data that went to a marker's will drop and, and how much they will drop after
surgery.
It's just, it's a speculation at this point.